[Music]
what's up guys
welcome back to culture binge the
wisecrack podcast where we get all types
involved in the cultural zeitgeist to
see what's going on
uh as always i am michael joined by the
bernie madoff of crypto art investments
alec
and the songbird of a generation serbia
alec and serbia how are you all doing
today
well thank you how are you just just
fantastic feeling really energetic alec
how are you
i'm i'm great we're a little taken off
guard by the bernie madoff thing but
i'm liking it i mean he was very
successful for a time
so i'm comparing you to a successful
period not his incarcerated period so at
least
have that um so we have a lot to get
into today as always
we're going to talk about digital art
we'll talk about innovations and dining
and dashing
and we will talk about why one of the
most important singer songwriters of the
generation
is upset but first let's talk about why
we are
happy and sad at various levels we'll do
slaps and chaps this is the part
where we all share something that's
really slapping for us the past couple
weeks and something that's champing
our behinds so uh serbia let's start
with you what are your slaps and chats
for this episode
so what slaps the undoing on hbo
i did not have high expectations going
in but i was pleasantly surprised
uh it was the kind of show where as soon
as it ended i wanted to
start the next episode uh i really liked
seeing hugh grant on screen
uh the other thing that slaps is um
my best friend from business school is
ready to date again
um she uh her relationship ended
last year so she's ready to date again
and i'm super excited for her
uh i have a request of for our viewers
if you have a
reya or raya invitation
if you could please send that my way
because she's currently on all the
dating apps and she's not here what's
wrong
i mean this in the best way possible i
don't think one of our listeners
has a raya invitation
we have a diverse audience
no but i don't mean about diversity i
mean raya is like
the historically slightly more douchey
influencer and see-less celebrity dating
app that you have to be invited to go on
so it's if you want to have like a late
night cuddle with john mayer you go on
raya and you hope for the best
safe sex john mayer
i want uh her so this is actually kind
of a selfish
request as well because i want her to go
on the app so this way she can go on
these dates and tell me what it's like
and then i can talk about it on culture
bench
yeah that's great content so if you want
good content
yeah so if you could please send me a
culture binge wisecrack.co an invitation
or however it works
um please do that if you want to know
what it's like to
date on this exclusive dating app um
what chaps i watched the show
away on netflix and it's about a space
crew
that goes to mars and i really liked it
it's so great it's
the uh effects are really good the
stories are interesting and i'm so
sad to learn that the show is cancelled
and
it's not coming back for a second season
and i'm gutted
so that's what chaps
thank you um alec how about you
slaps and chaps what do you got oh uh i
just read
this book that i thought was really
interesting it's called disobey by
frederick gross
uh uh he's a phosphorman um and just
gross like
g-r-o-s-z something like that okay yeah
uh but just talks about like uh the
kind of obedience and obviously
disobedience part of that through a lot
of like sort of historical figures and i
i thought it was really interesting
sounds fantastic as far as what chaps
uh nothing the world is perfect and i
resent this
this segment wow well there's uh the
prince of positivity the
opulent overlord of optimism alec
avoiding chaps once again
um i'll do mine real quick i kind of
want to do two slaps so maybe i will
very quickly they're related but
opposite things first lap
american idol been watching it loving it
um and it's a shock you would not think
that i would love that show
here's why i love it because in these
dark times it's like a pure celebration
of random ass people having creative
talent and hope and joy
and it's it's the most i've ever cried
in my life is just watching
uh american idol on sundays and also i
just like how nice they are
you know like so there's no more simon
cowell no it's lionel richie
luke bryant and katy perry and i low-key
i low-key stan katy perry she's just
funny she has these crazy outfits and
she's just really nice to people and
they seem to believe in them and even
when they tell them
they're not going to make it they're
like yo like here's three things to work
on we still believe in you
this might not be the best for you right
now but i don't know it's just kind of
it's it's a it's a truly feel good show
up until this point maybe it'll get
into bad vibes once they get past the
audition thing and then just in terms of
bad vibes watching
um since i've watched it i've still been
thinking about adam curtis's recent
documentary can't get you out of my head
which you can find
online which is basically about like why
we're all screwed uh and how deeply
we're screwed so maybe
watch the adam curtis thing then watch
american idol if you need to feel better
about it
um for chaps i'll just say this really
quickly
i was really annoyed by the online
discourse about
one line in one division that took over
the internet recently
um and the reason i didn't like it is
because it was sort of like
a a young person who's an aspiring
screenwriter being like i really like
this line it was great
and all these jaded old professional
screenwriters being like
[ __ ] you idiot and i just didn't like it
i feel like it was a bad vibe and i feel
like everyone's having
a bad year and i get it but i feel like
the vibes are getting a little too
froggy
and people should chill out a little bit
that's all that's kind of vague
what is what is grief but love
persevering and they're like this is the
greatest line ever written which i
i don't think most of us agree but no it
definitely knows him
but i think um there's a writer comedian
a very brilliant person heather anne
campbell who i'm a huge fan of
who tweeted something the effect of like
the line was fine
you all are being ridiculous are you
able to share what the line is or no
oh alex just said it uh what is that
what is grief but love persevering yeah
oh but it's a it's a goddamn superhero
show on disney
plus it's a fine line um but the most
annoying thing about it was
people roasting the person who said it
was good
and a lot of them were professional
screenwriters and it's like what are you
all talking about
that is like the stuff that gets made is
corny like that none of you
are freaking new wave french filmmakers
who are producing abstract art
on celluloid like the industry is a
market and
commercial driven thing where a lot of
stuff sucks um emily in paris rules the
world
so who are you all to act like you know
the people who are writing
for tv shows in hollywood are like the
scribes of a generation just so corny
bad vibes didn't like it yes i got real
negative and i apologize for that
watch american idol on abc sunday nights
8 p.m pacific time
okay well those are our slaps and chaps
thanks for doing those
even if alec is going to continue to
protest against chaps
um which is his right to do before we
get into our topics just a reminder
um subscribe rate review this podcast it
would be meaningful to us
and it'd be especially meaningful to us
if after you give us a five star rating
on whatever platform you choose to rate
us on
um i don't know you maybe tell us which
film genre
we would all be maybe you want to say
that
that alec has the vibe of like a late
80s cyberpunk movie
maybe you want to say serbie's vibe is
sort of like a mystery thriller
maybe i am i don't know
like it's a student film someone found
into trash can
or disney but i don't know burns is
specifically like a the genre of
50 year old disney movies that are very
problematic
disney movie yeah yeah yeah yeah so with
involved in steamboats and lots of like
southern songs
sung awkwardly and and with choruses of
birds singing them
so so once again just rate review let us
know what film genre you are we'd really
appreciate that
and um if you do that we'll read some of
them on here so that's always fun
but for our first topic and everyone i
barely understand what he's gonna get
into here
we'll see if you understand this alec is
going to tell us about some recent
grimes based drama around crypto
based digital art i don't think it's
drama but but
yeah news what
sorry what oh okay so it's not drama
it's a it's some some some news
some current events some happenings
around crypto art
yeah so um there's the thing these
things called nfts
they stand for non-fungible tokens uh
we'll sort of explain that in a second
but the the basic premise is that if you
have a one-of-a-kind art piece in in
real life
you know like a van gogh or something
you can spend millions of dollars
uh to buy it and be the only person that
has that sure there might be
uh replications forgeries etc but you've
got
the real [ __ ] so some people decided
that
they need that for uh digital things
that
have no scarcity like of course there's
you know a million different
replications of the same gif
gif whatever you want to call it so a
non-fungible token
is a way to sort of through blockchain
and cryptocurrency ascribe like a
singular
value non-fungible which means not sort
of tradable interchangeable etc
to a piece of digital art so if any of
you are familiar
with uh the neon cat which is the sort
of uh
cat animation with like a pop tart and a
rainbow coming out of it
uh an artist sold one of those for a ton
of money
uh grimes is is doing them lots of
people are selling these things for tens
of thousands of dollars or
hundreds of thousands of dollars um
so before i move on basic premise
it's a one-of-a-kind digital art piece
are we are we all on board so far yes
why can't i click
shift command 4 and just take a
screenshot of this
and then share it you can but there
won't be something on the sort of
blockchain ledger saying that it it's
yours you know it's like
it's a certificate of authenticity that
you get
with your limited edition michael jordan
okay so like when martin shkreli bought
that one-of-a-kind wu-tang clan album
even if someone then ripped that to the
internet he would still have
that original one-of-a-kind copy well
yeah he has a physical copy so it's a
way to replicate
i mean the thing about all this stuff is
that scarcity when you have a physical
object it's easy to say i have
the one in the original yeah so it's a
way to have digital scarcity
yeah a way to have digital scarcity so
specifically there there's a
insider article about grimes um
the article reads over the past few
weeks sales of non-fungible tokens or
nfts have taken off
uh nfts which operate as a unique type
of digital asset or token have in some
instances sold for millions of dollars a
piece
contributing to a crypto art market
that's valued at over 100 million
dollars grimes
had 10 nfts that brought in over 5.8
million dollars in under
20 minutes uh this is grime's uh
pop artist also uh married to
elon musk i think maybe the consensus is
grimes is cool and elon musk is less
cool or is grimes not all so cool
i would say grimes was really cool and
she's been less cool
not because she's married to elon musk
because we can't blame people for their
partner's wackness
but her a lot of her takes and views
have gotten very whack
since she's been the partner of elon
musk
yeah and i i think that flows nicely
into this next bold i have from this
article which is
one piece an image that depicts a baby
guarding mars
this is artwork done by i think by
grimes has garnered
significant attention trading at over
300 000 in under 10 minutes
the it's called newborn 2 nft has
already been
relisted after that that one auction at
2.5 million dollars
uh there's another piece called war
nymph appears as a baby to represent and
there's a quote
yeah we've got we've got some grimes are
and the art is uh
i mean i can't make this kind of art i'm
not gonna i'm not gonna knock the the
artistry behind it but i feel like in
terms of
is this good art i'll not get this is
stupid
yeah yeah yeah well like i think it's a
thing where like the artistry or like
the
the technical part of it is cool and
like it looks pretty but at the same
time the the art of it is dumb
uh so war nymph uh it's uh a state of
this is a quote a state of
infant infancy where she sheds her old
skin of corruption
the site says adding that she battles
the destructive forces of obsolete ideas
and systemic decay that threaten the
future
get it it's about eon musk's struggles
because
he's trying to burn the old system and
then send us all to mars in some
libertarian colony but anyway
uh that's the the sort of war and fury
uh series
um grimes is obviously not the only one
uh in february the digital comic artist
chris torres sold an nft of his neon cap
for nearly six hundred thousand dollars
uh we also joy can we put on the there's
the pepe
oh no that's all right well
so the the original artists who made
pepe what
uh sold for a ton of money uh it's a
homer simpson
pepifide and again i just want to remind
everyone the original artist of pepe
is not a bad person it was appropriated
by nazis
and then he tried to fight the nazis and
there's a documentary i haven't seen it
i've heard it's very good uh but that's
what's going on with nft
um nfts what i find interesting is that
uh i would say even in the real world
you have a physical copy or you're a
sneaker head you're trying to
get like it's all fake it's all you know
supply and demand and human psychology
there's no like inherent reason that
like gold should be valued what it is
but this is more fake in a way that
makes me feel deeply uncomfortable
i don't i don't like this
i just want to get involved in it like i
want to sell something
okay so you don't like it as art you
like it because you think it'd be dank
to have one of these commodities that
you could
make some bank off of 100 yeah yeah
that's i mean i mean listen like
if if i could just have a file and i
sell the file and make a bunch of money
what an easy way
to as the ancients would say secure the
bag
but i just think like as i just i just i
just don't
i would rather spend thousands of
dollars to just pay for like a really
good album or something
made by a musical artist rather than a
weird digital thing of a of a baby
throwing a spear at the earth to defend
the ideas of elon musk
but here's a question aren't you kind of
into sneaker head
slash type stuff i'm like limited
edition
yes i do enjoy a good
limited edition sneaker what's
so in terms of like obviously nike
could make as many of this kind of
sneaker but they arbitrarily like we're
only going to make 100 to drop the price
up
the scarcity in both cases is fake
what makes it is i'm not knocking you i
just wanted one i mean first of all
let's just say it nike just a good
company it's family owned it's
they produce things in a way that's
ethical and you feel good about yourself
when you buy stuff from there or you
have cognitive dissonance and you
convince yourself it's okay even though
you're aware that like a malaysian child
is probably making your shoes but um
i i guess the difference would be
there's still something like
functional about a shoe so even if
you're getting limited i mean
i'm not the type of person that like
puts things in a case and never wears
them even with limited edition things i
think they're fun to wear
um because then occasionally someone
working at like a cool coffee shop who's
younger than you might say like cool
shoes and you're like hey
you've still got it kid um
i don't know and i guess they're like
tied into culture in a certain way but
hey
maybe i'm just convincing myself that
there's a difference
where there is none but for me at an
intuitive level
a digital piece of blockchain
certifiable art feels different than a
physical good i agree i don't know how
you
like do you use that as like your
desktop background
like how do you look at it i think some
people i i think some people
can just like obviously you can display
in whatever way you want but you could
for instance
have like a little lcd screen or i'm
just going to call like put a [ __ ]
ipad on your wall and like have it as an
art piece
there's a samsung model tv that like the
whole thing about it is it looks like an
art frame
so i guess you could put it on your
samsung but then it's just like
it's just gonna waste time until you
watch another episode of stanley tucci
searching for italy on cnn
well i know like walmart or they used to
have the sort of digital picture frames
where you could put in a usb
drive and it would like scroll through
them so anyway get a 20
digital picture frame and then put your
dollar neon cat on it
or just don't know if i'm at someone's
house and they're like hey
here's this cool nft whatever you call
it
on their screen and i i think to myself
oh cool i also just looked that image up
and i have it on my screen and they're
like but technically it's mine and i'm
like
cool but technically i'm looking at the
same thing
yeah i think that's where i don't get it
whereas if someone has like a rothko in
their house
i can get a printing of a rothko
but they're going to have the version of
the painting that our guy
mark was like physically touching and
working on that represents the
materiality of the artistic creation
and not just a reproduction of that
thing so it almost feels like the
original itself
is the reproduction yeah but
so i agree with you in that it feels
wrong and it feels bad but i'm like
almost challenging ourselves because
again with like the original painting
what if you just had a really convincing
forgery
yeah and like does it at the like if
you've convinced yourself the forgery is
real
doesn't matter or if your friend has a
real and you have a forgery
what's the this is the same thing with
diamonds right you can't tell the
difference between a man-made diamond so
the diamond industry will make up ways
to be like you can totally
tell the difference because we put this
laser etching that's a real
and not a man-made diamond but the point
which like you can't
feasibly tell you know obviously there's
a difference between a mass manufactured
print of a picasso
and like a compelling forgery you know
what's the point here that just
everything boils down to the stories we
tell ourselves about ourselves and the
things we consume and once we dig a
little deeper we see that our entire
social existence is just a bunch of
interwoven false narratives
oh
[Laughter]
i just i feel like i'm surrounded by
technology all the time like i'm
constantly looking at a screen all day
for work
i have my phone i have a television the
last thing i want is another screen
in my face like shifting things like
shifting
pictures and stuff like i don't need
that i don't know why
but i'm not i'm not in i don't know i
feel like it's a very
interesting idea for a very niche group
of art enthusiasts any final thoughts on
crypto art this has been very
interesting i feel like we've all
learned a lot here
wow and oh sorry no
wow i i asked you all if you felt me and
the crowd left me stranded okay well
let's
move on um so
let's start with this okay um have
either of y'all
ever dined and dashed in your lives and
note that
anything you say on a podcast is not
usable for evidence in court
so that's not the law no dyna dash alex
you've ever done
that i don't think so i think it might
have been suggested by my friends once i
was like no we're not doing it yeah
okay either of us i think the closest
i've gotten was
getting food from a place that had a hot
bar and just eating it
and then leaving yeah
and didn't pay but it wasn't like a
restaurant it was like more like nobody
served you
no so i basically just stole food inside
of an upscale grocery store
um oh yeah that doesn't count yeah um
and before we get into this the reason
dining dashing is bad is because you're
screwing over an individual employee
who works off their tables and tips and
in some cases might have to pay for a
customer squeeze them over so never
dining dash but
one of the weirdest things that has
happened in the past year in the
restaurant industry
we've talked about sort of changes in
the restaurant industry and food
consumption and food delivery quite a
few times over the past year
but this is a story that kind of bummed
me out and it's about a new form of
dining and dashing
that's taking place that's actually led
to one of the most popular restaurants
in los angeles to shut down
um so yes the restaurant in question is
a place called
spoon by h and it's in the fairfax
district of los angeles
and it's a family-owned korean
restaurant that started as kind of like
a dessert and sandwich
cafe eventually started making um larger
dishes and noodle soups was still a
pretty small thing and then
very famous chef david chang of the
momofuku restaurant group
said it was his favorite restaurant in
like los angeles or something
all of a sudden you know place goes
through the roof gets very popular
now they have been managing to stay open
during the pandemic by making these like
large boxes with a bunch of different
stuff for them different types of like
meat pickled vegetables rice dishes
they're very good i had one for lunch
one day
but what started happening is people
started putting in very massive orders
picking them up and then disputing the
charges
with the company talk that they do their
orders through so talk is one of these
companies that restaurants use
to get orders for meals right now um one
of the orders that kind of set them back
the most was one for it was worth 728.76
someone put this order in someone came
and picked it up uh they didn't leave
vehicle information on their order which
is a standard thing
um the customer showed up the owner was
like let me help you take it to your car
and said the person acted kind of weird
but not too weird she brought it to this
customer's van
felt like she was just being a nice
person and helping out a customer
and then within like a day or two she
got an alert that the
charge was being contested and
eventually the money all got put on her
the owner of this small business so
rather than making almost 800
they lost both the cost of food and
labor and the 800
that the customer contested and this
kept happening
um to this particular restaurant and in
most cases um
the service sided with
the consumer or the scamming consumer
over the business now some of the
reasons has been happening i guess more
are that you know when when people are
taking orders digitally or by the phone
they're just taking your credit card
number they're not matching up your
credit card with an id
or a person or anything like that so
it's been a mix of people both
using scam credit cards they make an
order on the scam credit card
when the owner of the actual credit card
files for the fraud
the restaurant kind of gets screwed in
that case because they don't get that
money
or it's people using their own card or a
scam card
and then disputing the things so
restaurants have to do that there's some
other instances and there's an article
about this in the la times from a week
ago there's also an article on eater
about this thing you could look up if
you wanted to
but it's happened in a bunch of other
places there's a butcher shop in los
angeles
um that had some orders for over a
thousand dollars
uh that they said at the time didn't
seem too weird because a lot of
private chefs will sometimes call the
butcher shop and put in these big orders
um but one person put in an order for
six hundred dollars of meat over the
phone
the next week did thirteen hundred
dollars a meet over the phone then they
were both disputed so we're talking two
thousand dollars
and this isn't an industry that if
you've been keeping up with this
is is truly it's not dramatic to say
hanging on by the
thinnest of threats you know the
restaurant industry is one that has
horrible margins when the world is great
and the economy is booming
in these times it's been a lot of very
small teams
doing their best just to keep the lights
on and pay their employees
so i don't know it's a thing that kind
of shocked me to hear this was a thing
bums me out that people are taking
advantage of restaurants during
struggling time no you might be saying
michael didn't you just tell us a story
about you eating food from a place and
not paying for it
it was a chain business that screws over
their employees they're fine
okay they're fine um i'm just gonna
assume those whole foods
i'm not gonna say who i'm gonna say an
evil person owns the place so
they're just fine um an evil person
looks like les
lex luthor has a shaped head is based in
seattle recently went through a big
divorce
their ex-partner got the biggest
settlement in history but i don't know
maybe it's whole foods maybe it wasn't
um but very much bums me out here this
is happening
and kind of like scary that it's setting
a precedence that you can scam people
or or and you know in some of these
instances too the woman who runs this
place spoon by h in los angeles said she
started taking pictures of
every order before she gave it to the
customer and in a lot of instances
the customer would leave and immediately
file a thing that said not all of my
items were there
and she would have like photo evidence
to pick no no they were and she said in
those cases people would say oh never
mind i have found it in my car
but it just made it very apparent that
people were taking advantage of a
fragile restaurant industry
to [ __ ] them over it bums me out um
any thoughts on this new era of dining
and dashing
this is so sad it's really upsetting to
me
yeah i uh
obviously it's awful i i i'm kind of
curious in the the economics of
these pop like it doesn't sound like
they were using a delivery service but
whether it's ubereats or doordash or
seamless
you know as a person who's not dying
dashing i've had problems with like
refunds and stuff
and what you're saying is it seems like
i'm confused about why the business had
to pay like i could understand if
they're out 800
worth of food but they also had to pay
800 that's what i don't understand
yeah yeah so um with with this business
sorry with talk if i understand this
correctly
um you know the customer paid this money
then they filed a dispute for the
charges
um and then wait maybe i said this wrong
so they just didn't they they just like
got and then lost 800
but they just lost i'm assuming the the
food
and the labor attached right yeah so
okay
so so here's like from the article on it
yeah so it says this um in january talk
let her know that she had lost her
appeal and that she was responsible for
the 728 and 76 dollars
so it probably was deposited in her
account and now she has to give it back
i think it just means that she had to
refund it but also
for instance if they were taking a cut
out of it did they also have to repay
the cut
these are all questions if you work in a
restaurant i want to know because from
my perspective
not dying dashing but i've had with a
delivery service that i
i don't want to promote and i want to
stop using all together
uh just like a ton of problems of like
food getting picked up and never getting
there so i've gotten like all these
refunds and credits
but i think it's the service's fault but
i also suspect the restaurant might be
paying for this
the [ __ ] ups of like the delivery people
and that would make you
even shittier yeah yeah in the same la
times article there's some examples from
some businesses that use
postmates and doordash and in those
instances someone said that on postmates
they have been able to get reimbursed
the example here is like on a postmates
order a customer requested a full refund
for a restaurant's
dish because they said it was the wrong
size but the restaurant only serves the
dish in a single size
so the restaurant owner was able to send
a photo to postmates explain the sizing
it was reimbursed
so in some of the delivery services it
sounds like those owners have had
better luck getting those things but it
seems like even in the instances
where they're using delivery services
that are i guess a little more amenable
to restaurants
the restaurant owners are having to go
through all these extra layers of effort
to document everything with photos
just to be ready to defend themselves
because that's how much
these things are coming up and in some
instances as well when they freeze the
charge
days or weeks might go by where a
restaurant doesn't have access to the
money they should have been paid
for the dish in question and from the
article in l.a times at least one of the
commonalities is it happens a lot on
really large orders
so the point is as well if you're
running a struggling restaurant
that thousand dollars you're out might
be a really big deal
if that's frozen for a week or two yeah
totally
yeah it seems like in the case that i'm
thinking which
again well two things i think it's
probably worse because people feel like
maybe
not in this case because they were
picking it up and then charging it back
but i feel
with cmos store dash etc there might be
an added component of like i don't
actually have to see a person i feel
like i'm scamming doordash when in
reality they might be scamming
somebody else depending on the policies
of the company whatever um
but also with the delivery thing yeah i
don't know
it's just all so [ __ ] up and these
companies
i've been refunded so much from one
delivery service because the nobody came
to pick up the order
i'm like they would have kicked me off
if they were paying for it
like the restaurant must be making the
food and throwing it out which also
makes me feel awful which is why i don't
want to use the service
i mean it does feel like the delivery
services are in the best position
because a lot of the problems can be put
on to
either the delivery drivers or the
restaurants themselves
and it seems like that's and i don't
understand the full legality of this but
i know
in terms of the the delivery services
treating everyone involved as like
private contractors and treating
themselves as simply a platform
for the transaction rather than a
business it seems like that gives them a
legal liability
such that they're not on the hook for
any of this so that the people getting
screwed over
are underpaid drivers and struggling
restaurants
rather than the billion-dollar funded
silicon valley corporations that created
the platforms
yeah that makes me sad too because
recently
i've been ordering um most of my orders
from either instacart or whole foods
have had some kind of a
problem um like for example i ordered
flowers from whole foods and when i
opened
the flowers up they were all um a lot of
the
like rosebuds were like cut off the
stems
and so i was like how did that happen
yeah so it
seems like maybe some kid maybe like
ripped them off or whatever
um and so when i like said there was a
problem with the product
after i did it i thought oh no does the
driver like does the driver get
in trouble for that like are they going
to get penalized or
does the money just get refunded from
whole foods so same thing with instacart
i cut apples and all the apples were
rotten inside
so are the is the driver
like when i say the quality is bad does
the driver get penalized or is it
the like instacart so if you are
if you work at one of those places so
now i just haven't been disputing
anything
because i don't know who gets in trouble
and i don't want the delivery person to
get in trouble
so i just throw everything away yeah and
that's a rough position to be in as like
let's let's call it an ethical consumer
who
doesn't want to screw over you know a
delivery driver
or or a business owner or whatever yeah
i guess it can lead to situations like
that where maybe then we are you don't
want to complain because you don't want
to screw someone over but it's like
whose fault is it and then if we're not
complaining or
you know because of that worry then
bezos and co
are good to go yeah it's just a big
bummer um
though the one positive angle on the
story in los angeles is the restaurant
spoon by h
someone did set up a gofundme for them
they didn't set it up themselves
and raise 50 000 in like a week because
they were
a beloved restaurant so they they might
i guess
try to reopen but they as of a week ago
they officially closed down because they
were unsustainable uh with all the
disputed charges that were happening but
i don't know if anyone who's listening
to this is a scammer don't do that type
of scam
you know scam a major corporation steal
food
from a big business just make sure
you're not screwing over local
businesses that are trying their best
you know
yeah or don't do any crimes i don't know
yeah
crime is we don't we don't stand for
crime yeah but is it
is it a crime if you're just trying to
eat isn't that what lei
miserable is about which i've never seen
nor read okay
um all i know about it is memes
involving anne hathaway
okay you do that you're not a nice
person if you're listening to this and
you've done something like
this that's you should have higher
standards for yourself
and don't be unkind that way well and it
brings up the question too of
would people do things like this if they
had to look people in the eyes when they
did it you know do all these
layers of digital distance make it
easier for us to act like sociopaths
because the people don't seem real just
an app yeah yeah some people would still
be doing it but more people are gonna do
it because they don't i mean like
same thing when you steal a bunch of
credit cards you're not thinking about
all the people
and to be honest like my credit card's
been stolen it's been almost
it's been fine so whoever stole my
credit card
i don't mind so i have an unrelated
story it's just really embarrassing i
have to share it so
my credit card information was
compromised during like a big hack at a
big store
so my credit card company kept sending
me new credit cards like every
every month or so to prevent like
i don't know fraud or whatever so i
would be at a restaurant
with friends or whoever and my credit
card kept getting declined
and like after the third time with the
same person
the guy was like are you having credit
issues like
you in a financial bind oh
the card decline thing that isn't knock
on wood that hasn't happened to me in a
while but gosh when i was in my mid-20s
it was always that constant fear
sometimes of like just giving someone a
card and being like i hope this works
not because it was hacked because i was
broke um that's horrible
um okay so stop here by saying
scam ethically don't be a dick and do
stuff like this
don't dine and dash in any way shape or
form it's not good it's screwing over
local businesses it's bumming us out
um speaking of people who are bummed out
who are pissed who
feel like injustice has been done to
them siri tell us why taylor swift
is upset oh taylor swift okay so
first let me give you some context
there's a new show on
netflix called ginny in georgia it's
about a woman
and her teenage kids who move to a new
town and the mom is a bit immature
and there's quite a bit of
mother-daughter tension basically it's
like a lamer version of gilmore girls if
anybody has seen that
and if anybody has seen that yes we've
seen gilmore girls
uh anyway there's been a lot of buzz
about the show and it's currently
uh the top viewed show on netflix right
now
um and it the show probably would have
like faded into
obscurity if a tweet
wasn't sent yesterday and the tweet in
question was sent by taylor swift
who said the following hey ginny in
georgia
2010 called and it wants its lazy deeply
sexist
joke back how about we stop degrading
hard-working women by defining this
horse [ __ ] as
funny also netflix after miss americana
this outfit doesn't look cute on you
happy women's history month i guess
and miss americana is a taylor swift
documentary that was released on netflix
uh about a year ago and she also
included a broken heart emoji
um so she tweeted this in response
to a joke that was said and
the scene so let me set the stage so the
the mother just found out that the
daughter is sexually active the daughter
i think is like 15.
um and at one point during this argument
the daughter says
what do you care you go through men
faster than taylor swift
so this taylor swift tweet has set off a
firestorm of reaction
so uh on one side we have all of her
fans who are bombarding
the twitter the netflix twitter account
with angry messages
um every tweet the company says or
company sends out about
you know whatever any marketing
promotional thing they have going on
uh the taylor swift fans will go and and
all the replies are about taylor swift
uh the actors in the show are receiving
negative comments
the uh young actress who said
the the joke um is particularly being
targeted
on uh instagram and
a lot of publications are debating the
merits of the joke
and uh whether taylor swift was
right in um feeling upset and so
this is the line of thinking that i've
seen emerging
um the one where people are are finding
taylor swift's reaction a bit
hypocritical
and um before i start so this way no
taylor swift fans come after me
i don't i'm not saying taylor swift is
wrong and feeling upset
um but the reason why people feel like
her reaction uh is a is a bit
strange is that she's made a career
as a singer-songwriter who puts her
personal life
at the forefront of her music so
one of the prominent ways she writes
songs is that she talks about her
relationships she talks about
how many men she's dated or not how many
men excuse me
how her relationships have not worked
out
and in one of her songs she even says i
have a long list of
ex-lovers and she talks about these
relationships in her music and in
interviews so the argument that these
people feel
is that the writers on the show are
merely repeating what she's
already said herself and
i think the joke is lame and i think
it's kind of a lazy attempt at humor
i think resorting to the to the
uh storyline of a woman who dates around
is kind of a [ __ ] like i think
that's like we're done with that kind of
joke now um
but i do find it interesting that
people feel like she has relinquished
her right to feel offended
just because she has incorporated her
dating history as part of her narrative
and
um i started to think about that like
the idea of forfeiting
our right to be offended in situations
just because of
of how we've presented ourselves in the
past or some of the things
so our like our personal history um so
anyway what do you think
i i don't think it's
i think forfeiture of your ability to be
pissed at things is maybe the wrong
framework but
what i think is well here's a question
about the joke
whether it's a good or bad joke is it a
joke like ha ha
taylor swift is like a [ __ ] or is the
joke like ha ha
taylor swift is like romantically
unsuccessful like i i feel like
you know don't make fun of your female
friends for sleeping around in the same
way that dudes do but if it's like
you know for instance i might make fun
of a boomer for being divorced five
times that's not about promiscuity but
that's about like their inability
to you know find a good partner stuff
like that and so like
which what do you have a sense of like
what side that joke was on
no but but it sounds like too the joke i
mean
it wasn't about taylor swift it's a it's
a character
making fun of her mom using the
reference of a celebrity
who for better or worse is known to have
had a lot of boyfriends
yeah so it's and it's it is a lazy type
of contemporary humor which is and
someone
put this on twitter a long time ago i'm
starting to not like credit them but
they did this little graph that was like
contemporary humor two overlapping
circles and it's like one cultural
reference another cultural reference in
the middle we have joke
um so it's lazy it's not like a good
joke but
but i also think the other thing is and
this is also i think
from some kind of tweet and sorry to the
original author but the
the other tricky thing is it's not that
like
there's i think an idea going around
that fictional characters need to be
like standard bearers of like morality
like capital immorality
which like isn't true maybe the purpose
was
to have the daughter say an insensitive
hurtful thing that is problematic in a
lot of ways but like that was the show
writer's intent
maybe it wasn't maybe the show writer i
was like
ha haha taylor swift [ __ ] joke funny or
something like that and so
i don't know so i don't think taylor
swift has forfeited her right to be mad
at stuff at the same time there's a
certain irony to like
bully these people not that she's saying
this but like having
her fans bullying people who were not
involved in the writing of the joke
such as the actress who said it to be
like you're an awful person
i think there's there's so many levels
of fucked-upness in what's happening
yeah i'm just kind of out on this one i
think that like
sadly for better or worse like that's
what contemporary humor has become
in tv shows and like adult animated
shows it's just a barrage of pop culture
references
sadly for her i guess taylor swift is
one of the most famous people on the
planet
um and her personal life is also known
about kind of in the same way
a very lazy joke made in a lot of things
as like any joke about
leonardo dicaprio um you know he hasn't
dated anyone older
than a college student or whatever might
be they're just like you know it's a
thing that happens and obviously we live
in a misogynistic culture so joking
leonardo dicaprio is different than
joking about taylor swift
but i don't know it's like it's a dumb
joke things like that are said a lot
about a lot of people in the public eye
taylor swift has infinity dollars until
she brought this to light i had never
heard of the show
i imagine a lot of people had never
heard of the show until she brought it
to light
um and now the fact that like a young
woman is getting attacked by taylor
swift's fans to defend another woman
like
it's clear here that the motivation
isn't let's defend
women from patriarchal culture it's we
are zealots for taylor
and we will dance in your blood if you
desecrate her spirit
yeah and i just think it's like a weird
version
of stan culture and i also think it's
just like
i don't know like okay for example
sometimes especially after like certain
wisecrack videos
i'll get a random tweet from someone
with one follower and no
and no user image that says something
really mean to me now what i normally do
is think these are funny and i just
don't respond
but if i then retweet that and say what
a horrible person
then a bunch of people are seeing this
thing then the thing is getting
attention i realize it's not going to
compare myself to taylor swift that's
not what i'm doing but there's exactly
like taylor swift
listen as well we're the same height
we're the same height um we both
play guitar you were public feud with
kanye west i was in public studio kanye
west
and i have also i dated john mayer when
i was very young
yeah same sex save sex yes safe sex john
mayer
i love that reference i am glad i have a
shout outs to anyone listening who gets
the reference
but i know you don't alec and i'm not
going to tell you i like that serbia and
i
get a thing that you don't it's fun um
but i don't know i i do think this is
overblown and i also say that getting
i'm just like a dude and maybe there's
some irony in me not taking it seriously
but i i think the thing is a little
overblown
and i think if you have infinity dollars
sometimes just like enjoy your infinity
dollars
i feel like i'm have a hard time
believing that this is the worst joke or
the worst thing that somebody has said
about taylor swift that she needed
you know what [ __ ] this this is deeply
sexist
kanye west at a song where he talked
about like [ __ ] her
and that was a whole thing that was
maybe not nice even though she then
there was a call where she said on the
phone with kim that it was okay
sneaky snake emojis
yeah it seems like also
i i i hate to do this about like
i i hate people someone's like this bad
thing happened to me and i'm a woman and
they're like
obviously you're doing it for the
publicity i i don't i'm that's bad
however is it like taylor swift
especially with the kanye thing maybe
has a history
of being mad at things for publicity
purposes
yeah well also too taylor swift's in
this period of her career where i think
like everyone's moved past the weird
kanye beef
um she's put out two really great
records
during the pandemic that have
highlighted her artistry and made it
very clear that she truly is like a
fantastic musician
it's just sort of like now that you're
at that point in your career i just
think it's dumb to engage in this type
of [ __ ]
because you know what like there's a lot
of famous singer songwriters and artists
and filmmakers that people talk [ __ ]
about on the internet or on netflix
shows that no one's going to watch after
two weeks
at a certain point you got to let that
go
and and i think there's a line i don't
know exactly where the line is
but like if you are a public figure
people are going to continue to make
dumb jokes about you in stand-up and
dumb comedy shows and in their tweets
and at a certain point i just don't know
how
how worth it it is to engage with those
sort of things so
serbie do you think she's given up her
right to be mad at
that seems to be both of your takes i
don't think
i don't think she has given up her right
but i agree with burns that i think she
should
i think she's um at that point in her
career where this
should not be the hill she's gonna die
on
yeah i mean to quote her friend kanye
west on this one there's a line i forget
what song it's from the graduation album
where he says
yeah i think he could but i don't think
he should
and i think that logic is here could
taylor swift reasonably get mad at this
and make a public thing sure
do i think she should nah i think it's
irresponsible of her too like she knows
how passionate her fan base is
what did she expect was going to happen
like they're going to attack
the show like the the actors and stuff
like that like how
yeah an actor who's like let's say this
netflix doesn't pay a lot everyone i'll
just say that netflix screws their
actors over more than anyone else
open secret so some young actor maybe
this is their first big gig who got paid
[ __ ] to be in the show
is now getting attacked by people
because she read a line she was paid to
say because it was her job and she was
doing it
i don't know i just i think that's
shitty the the last thing i'll say
is the amazing twitter comedian who
pretended to be the author yes
the creator of emily in paris is now
doing this with that show
and just like yeah i wrote that joke
taylor you got a problem and i hope she
ends up on bbc
she got so many she's been posting like
dms of taylor swift fans who are like
[ __ ] kill yourself
i also love that too these people that
are like defend taylor by telling
strangers to like die
yeah just know what no one ever be never
be a fan of anything i think that's the
main lesson
yeah like like things but just don't
really be a fan of people listen
i'll say it about all my passions they
will all disappoint me someday
uh and they probably suck in some way
and that's okay
listen i love bruce springsteen's music
he made a stupid super bowl commercial
and i can deal with that because i'm
obsessed with the person i appreciate
the art that he makes
um speaking of appreciating people
we appreciate you and we appreciate when
you call us we appreciate when you email
us
it means a lot to us um i truly have
i sometimes everyone so you know this i
want to write back to emails a lot but i
still don't know if i'm allowed to
you're allowed friends and fans okay so
i just learned this i often want to
write back to an email and be like oh
that's a good question that's blah blah
but i'm like am i allowed to
i don't know um you know our hr
department never walked me through that
in my onboarding process
so so now i can write back and call back
i'll call you too leave your numbers
don't leave your numbers but you can
email us at culturebinge
wisecrack.co no m culturebridge
wisecrack.com and call us at
213-534-8807 that is 213-534-8807
we love it it means a lot to us we we
consider you a part of the community
part of the family and if you don't talk
to us we're just talking to avoid like a
bunch of
dummies so alec what do we got this time
uh the first one we've got a voicemail
can we play that
hi this message is in regards to your
last culture binge my name is arielle
and i just say
uh i am from nevada michael and the way
you said nevada made me cringe
so hard it's nevada it's very important
to that and to say nevada
and serpie got it right so i'm very
happy for the got it right but um
yeah it's interesting about this company
town thing that uh steve sithalak
is promoting um it seems
that it would be in areas that are
technically outside already established
areas representatives taking in new
areas but
i do agree it's concerning it doesn't
remind me of company towns
and uh yeah i can't say i'm completely
signing on but
i can't agree it's not a crazy
republican he's writing this date it
seems just like it was a democrat so
all kind of strange but all right thanks
and you guys do a great show bye
thank you i'm sorry so it's nevada
i'm never going to remember it like can
i just say this in my defense i was
i was raised and educated primarily east
of the mississippi
the west is has been another country to
me my whole life
i had not been to the west until i was
an adult i'm learning
and i i thank you in teaching me these
things
just call california california
california or something
i just call it cali oh
i know if i really talked like that i
would want to never mind i almost said
something
violent i i would not like myself if i
was someone who talked like that um
yeah all right so
uh that's the last voicemail but we also
have
some great emails i think we have time
for two the first one is from ben
about vaccines it's our favorite topic
specifically
what is the morality of getting a
vaccine in certain circumstances i love
to
to
rack my brain about this but this is
from ben uh hi i live in maryland to
have a medical condition that puts me in
cdc's special prioritization group 1c
but maryland for whatever reason put me
in group 2. maryland
is also behind in its rollout and seems
to have stalled at the moment in 1c
would it be wrong to lie about my
category
since i should belong in category 1 see
and skip in line in maryland or go to dc
where i lie about my residence and get
my shot there
i am a transplant recipient and the
fatality rate for people like me is one
in five there is even a good opinion
piece on cnn
from a transplant recipient who got her
shot sooner just because of her job
i feel like it'd be okay since maryland
screwed up but i feel like jumping in
line could just be reinforcing my
privilege as a white upper class
uh male who has a job that can tell work
for the foreseeable future
i could be jumping in line in front of
more vulnerable people who don't have
that luxury
however at the same time my wife works
in school and i'll return soon and i
have an
infant starting daycare soon that would
expose me to it i'm torn what do you
think
thanks ben
why are you putting this on us ben i i
want to preface this by saying
uh legally i don't think i can encourage
you to do a fraud
but i will just say like on the ethics
of breaking crime from a philosophical
standpoint
um i think you're
fine here's the thing and like there are
people in my life with with similar
things like
i think lots of people make excuses
about why they should have a vaccine and
i think most of them don't i don't think
you're one of those people
i think some people are like oh well i'm
a perfectly healthy 25 year old but i
wanna really wanna do this like
non-essential travel and therefore like
i'll get it so i'm gonna lie and say i
work
you know at my friend's restaurant but
you're not one of those people like
you seemingly have like a huge chance of
dying from coronavirus you're probably
like listen there is a broad range of
sort of health statuses among people who
are 65 or over 75
you're probably better off than some 75
year olds but worse off than other 75
year olds and so
you know when the state the government
makes these things they're sort of
imperfect categories
um i think we should do our best to
abide by them but i think
for people in severe circumstances like
you i don't think
i'm gonna sit around and be like did you
hear about ben who's got a liver
transplant
and you know decided to to skip in line
like i don't
i don't think it's that i mean the other
case i know
is uh i know a couple people who are at
risk and have shitty
state rollouts and so traveled state
lines and maybe they didn't ask right
questions
i know in another state it was like you
needed two co-morbidities so
having cancer wasn't enough you need to
like have cancer and smoke so maybe
people fudge those things
i'm not mad at those people i'm mad at
the people who are like
you know i don't need this but i'm gonna
get it and also at the same time i think
people are legally eligible
uh people who work at hospitals but
maybe work from home and i don't think
they're bad people i think
they are not gonna sit around and let
vaccines go to waste
um so i'm saying like lots of eligible
people are getting it who are probably a
lot lower risk than you
and they shouldn't even feel bad about
it if they're legally allowed to do so i
don't think you should feel bad about it
if i heard this story i would not be mad
at you if you got the vaccine
yeah i think that's a good way to put it
yeah i think if i had a friend in your
situation and they did it i wouldn't
judge them
i probably wouldn't do it but i'm i have
i have issues with
feeling like uh anything i do is is
hurting others
it's a problem i'll bring it up with my
therapist um
but i think like you know there's the
people who are literally scamming their
way in and there's a thing that happened
in la recently where there's been these
codes that were meant for people of
color and vulnerable communities
at a certain testing site and a bunch of
like white bougie people started texting
the codes around and being like no it's
like a fema testing site let's go get
tested and those people i think could
like
go swim in the ocean with bricks for
shoes and i wouldn't care
um i think in your case ben you know i i
think that's reasonable and i think like
alec kind of pointed out
the blame for a lot of this is on the
people and
responsible for the roll out at a
systematic level and not if the
individuals caught in a difficult system
so um
just don't tell us what you do because i
don't want to have that on my conscience
just be safe i i also think if you feel
like guilty about like
you know you work from home but are
exposed in these ways you know
help other people i don't know how you
would help them and again i cannot
legally recommend any kind of fraud
but just like you know you got yours
help other people get theirs
yeah like kiss lonely people on the
mouth yeah that's how the antibodies
transform yeah
you say i'm
your best friend so my best friend uh
the one who's
ready to date again she randomly got
called in to get her
vaccine um i don't know if it was like a
glitch in the system or what happened
but she
struggled with it a lot and then her
sister who's a physician just encouraged
her to get it
because they needed to just get vaccines
done um
so she went and got it but because she's
young healthy and vaccinated now and
she felt super guilty she's now going to
volunteer
at either vaccine sites or um
food pantries and things like that to
help people
so there are ways that you could offset
your guilt
and use your vote get this person aria
account everyone look at this this is a
person who gets their vaccine and says
you know what
i am now going to take this
responsibility on and do something for
others
get this person on raya let's get them
hooked up with some celebs
she'll if we get her the raya thing
she'll have to tell us the stories
anonymously
everyone wins yeah i'm i'm all about uh
feeling
deeply uncomfortable with ourselves as a
way to force ourselves to be better
people like i think
we should all just feel bad that we're
monsters
and then go from there you know like it
um do we have is there another email
alex yeah one more good luck then
one more good luck ben yeah good luck
ben oh sorry do you have to go right now
no i know i'm okay okay uh one more
email this one is from adam
the question's directed at michael but
adam said whoever it's open for everyone
i am a college student studying to
become a social studies teacher however
i've recently been thinking about
pursuing teaching college
i'm currently working on my bachelor's
degree and i know at most universities
professors are required to have a phd
which means more time spent in school
and more student debt i'm also a
non-traditional age student and i'm set
to graduate with my bachelor's at the
age of 32
so time is sort of a commodity for me my
question is
getting a phd worth it and is academia
all that great
it looks like a lot of work getting
there but also seems like a lot of fun i
know i want to teach however at times
i'm unsure if i truly want to pursue
secondary education on the flip side
most of my professors aren't the most
approachable and sway to the pretentious
side
i feel like they wouldn't be great the
greatest co-workers meanwhile i know so
many primary and secondary teachers and
they're cool as hell
every time i ask a professor for advice
i get half-assed answer michael with
your experience in academia do you have
any thoughts or advice
michael you're gonna have the good
answer but can i give my short lesson
formed answer first
i was very interested in becoming a
professor to teach
especially earlier it's still appealing
to me but as i understand it michael
please verify this
you are mostly stuck publishing or
perishing
and the teaching part kind of sucks
michael what do you think if what you
want to do is be a teacher um i would
recommend maybe finding a way that you
could get
a like masters in education that's paid
for by someone else
not you whether it's through a teacher
training program or something like that
and look into like middle school or high
school teaching here's the deal if you
graduate with a with a ba 32
you'll probably finish your phd assuming
you get in
your first time applying and you might
not you might have to apply for a few
years
you might have to move some place you
don't want to move to you might get a
stipend that's really low so you're
going to take out some loans on top of
that so you can just like live a
lifestyle that's appropriate to a person
in their mid 30s
finish your phd by about 40 and then in
your 40s
you will be competing for jobs a lot of
them being visiting jobs
where if you beat out the other 300
applicants you might have the privilege
of a two-year contract where you make 45
to 50 000
a year probably with health benefits
definitely no 401k or anything like that
putting you in a position then where you
are hoping by your mid-40s
you get a 10-year track job where you
maybe start at like 60 000 65 000
potentially moving to a part of the
country you don't want to live in but
knowing that your only
option in a situation where you
increasingly have to teach more and
while teaching more
there could be like alec pointed out a
pressure to publish
even if you have nothing to say even if
your whole motive is i just want to
teach i want to help people i want to be
your own young students which is
[ __ ] a rad motivation you might be
pressured to write things that you don't
even need to write that the world
doesn't
need because maybe you write a few good
papers or one good book and you're
psyched with that for a little bit um
it's a really rough game and
a lot of cards are stacked against you
and i would say
if the motivation is to teach then i
would consider ways you can do that
outside of having to get a phd and also
too i i
i will try to remember to email you but
please if you hear this um feel free to
email again with any further questions
i'm happy to talk to you about this
so what about if he were to get a
master's and try to teach at a community
college assuming that he's based in the
us
um even then if you get a master's
degree the
your best bet with a community college
is they let you do some adjunct courses
so you're getting
between eighteen hundred and twenty four
hundred dollars to teach a course
um community college jobs are about as
competitive
as four-year universities at this point
so with a master's degree
you know if if there's a community
college job that goes up they're going
to get
hundreds of applicants with phds so
it's you're still going to be kind of in
a [ __ ] out of luck position in a lot of
cases
yeah i i know a person who teaches uh
they've got a career they're a
researcher but they teach
a public health class at their alma
mater
uh in the first couple years i think
they were pretty psyched about it
it doesn't pale up the full-time job
it's not their financial stability
and i think you know after the third
year of just teaching this one class it
became a grant which isn't to say that
it would become a grind for you but i
think
um kind of like the masters thing of
like maybe
maybe find ways to sort of like kind of
like teach on the side
if you really want to like i i would
personally love to do that even though i
know it's a horrible career but like i
have a job
i think it would be cool to teach on the
side yeah if you have a master's degree
and you live in a place where you have
access to a few different institutions
many of which aren't like you know
tier one you could probably get in there
and like teach a class
if that's just like what you want to do
but i don't know i
just think if you if you're interested
in teaching a subject that is taught at
high schools
or middle schools or whatever i would
just go that route
um i'm remembering too that the pay at a
lot of public middle schools and high
schools is just as much as you would get
starting out at university
um and in a lot of cases you still get
pretty good benefits and have some
strong unions in certain places to look
out for you but
yeah and i suppose if you were to teach
like
junior year or like senior year students
especially like in advanced courses then
wouldn't they
be just as like um
what's the word like not smart but like
just as engaged as like like college
students please
i think just as engaged and the problem
with college students in a lot of cases
is they're like overworked or ready
they're
you know and this isn't bad i don't
morally judge them for this but they're
like partying a lot doing other stuff
it just might not be a priority i think
that i i know i've friends that teach
at the middle school and high school
level that have a lot of positive things
to say about it so
um but we should probably wrap up here
gone for a little bit so
thank you so much for all these calls
and questions we want more of them so
culture binge wisecrack.com for the
email 213-534-8807 for the phone
and also just shout out to everyone who
after our last episode
joined that um hi-ho beta and that we've
been able to talk to on that app that's
been fun
so do that as well if you want to talk
to us there um before we end
if you do want to bug us in a way that
doesn't involve email or text
you can find us on the internet um or at
home
serbia what's your internet home where
can they find you
siripatel22 on twitter alec
where can people find you whether it's
an apartment in
new york or a twitter at where would
they find you
you can find me mask lists in the park
making out with strangers or on twitter
at what
i'm michael o'burns on on the the good
old social medias
um and we will be back in two weeks
so we will uh see you hear from you then
we'll probably be streaming live that
time too which is really exciting so
catch us then and have a great march
[Music]
you